(crew laughing)
- I knew you were going to say this,
I could like feel you in this corner.
(chill lounge music)
- Two very different shows
that I've been binging?
"Workin' Moms".
Catherine Reitman is just a comic genius.
I've loved that discovery
and I'm so grateful
that season two and three
came out so close together,
thank you Netflix!
Then, "Unbelievable",
starring Kaitlyn Dever.
And it was just, yeah,
the most astonishing
performances across the board,
Toni Collette, oh yeah, incredibly moving.
It depends!
I think if there's a
good song in the intro,
I'll sit through that, yeah.
I'd like to think I'm
retaining some of that patience
and attention span.
♪ All things know, all things know ♪
♪ You had to find it ♪
♪ All things go ♪
Sweet always.
I just recently watched "The Great Hack",
I think that would be
something that fascinates her,
especially the lead woman in it,
the lead (chuckles) the main focus woman,
yeah, very fascinating.
I don't know if I'd want
to go near any of them,
I've, either very
intimidating or very scary.
Maybe Sky.
Sky or...
Or James.
Oh no, in fact Payton's
father, played by Bob Balaban.
I guess returning to "Friends"
is always the guilty pleasure,
the familiarity with all
these characters, yeah.
It's such a timeless
show, 'cause you kind of,
you align yourself with
different people all the time,
but I guess fail safe is
always Phoebe I think.
Oh River.
River's so reliable
and trustworthy, River.
Probably David as well, I would trust him.
Theo, Theo heart of gold, Theo.
"Harold and Maude".
I want to choose something old and cool,
but I feel like...
"Mad Men" is kind of undeniable.
Elisabeth Moss's character...
Peggy.
She's so cool, she's so...
Yeah, just inherently cool.
I just picture her
walking out of the office
with her, the box of her
things and a cigarette
in her mouth so, Peggy.
I guess, yeah, I guess I'd want
to be on "Stranger Things",
yeah, "Stranger Things".
(chill lounge music)